you operate the firm according to the  principles right more or less but it's  very constant self-examination employees  have to be self-examined by their peers  you're self-examined by your peers right  or other people in the firm it's hard to  get people to want to do this and when  they be examined so intently over the  years and it's not easy  it's so logical but that doesn't mean  everybody wants to do it um  it's um so in one sentence it's an idea  meritocracy  you know the best ideas win out from  wherever they come from in which the  goals are meaningful work and meaningful  relationships that we're in it together  uh through radical truthfulness and  radical transparency so if we disagree  that's a good thing that's no reason to  have anger and to have the art of  thoughtful disagreement and examine how  do you scientifically find out what's  true how do you test things and so on  and that's been essential to our success